okay today's topic someone's telling me
this tick tock
i am oh no no no no no no no no no no
we're doing we're doing white people
crying again
i didn't see a white person i just saw a
human being so appreciate you not
interjecting race into this
i'm honestly not even embarrassed that i
look like this or that i'm doing this
right now
or if it makes me look
crazy whatever i don't give a [ __ ]
anymore honestly
do not date a woman for three months and
i use that term loosely date because he
never took me on a date or even playing
one in the house mr anxiety do not date
a woman for three months
[ __ ] her
lead her to believe you want a
relationship literally spend a whole
entire week with her and then ghost her
for four days and dump her and then tell
her it's just because you don't have
romantic feelings for her
why yeah
what the [ __ ]
i'll take it back we already had this
conversation before
what conversation was that
ghosting well i think in this case i
think she felt led on so i'll give you a
bit of context the individual in
question was just coming out of marriage
just recently got divorced and then
started dating her which she was aware
of
um and they never ended up going on
dates they mostly met up at his place
and they were banging
and i guess maybe some conversations
were had where she felt led on and he's
like oh you know i can't say that she
was let on that's just one side of the
story
right
the ghost thing part if it really
happened i'm not really for that you
know i mean you scold someone for four
days that's a bit wack that's why
but leading i cannot know if she was let
on or some [ __ ] and i can't understand
that she feels pains or whatever what
not
but then again
it's not because someone
something is not working with someone
that you were let on
it's not because someone some people
could try some [ __ ] out
it could last three months
and then
it don't work not because we're
necessarily let on you know what i mean
how many days did they go on
zero
neither outdoors or indoors
they were just going to his place and
smashing
yeah i understand that
three months
okay listen
you know when it comes to these things i
think there's certain clues that people
have to kind of
get in on to understand what's going on
in front of them
i don't understand that you're expecting
to become somebody's girlfriend when
you're not getting the girlfriend
experience this person not taking out on
dates this person is taking out his
stuff if they're not really talking
about a future per se probably not
getting interested in making you their
girlfriend
they only call you in at midnight to
come over to place in smash
why would you think that at some point
you're going to turn into their
girlfriend i don't understand that
irrespective of what they said i'm
talking about you as an individual if
you are dating somebody you have to
start to think about like
what is this really going to turn out
into based off of the actions this
person has taken not what they say but
the actions
right in the same token if i was getting
involved with a girl okay she just
wanted to go out to dinner to expensive
spots but never wanted to put out and
never wanted to really talk about going
things forward she wants a free meal and
at some point i have to take
accountability for the fact that just
because she's talking to me and showing
me attention doesn't mean she's really
into me we also have to be able to read
all the signs you get what i'm saying
guys
let me talk to you for two seconds do
you have bad credit i know i said that
loud don't even worry i've been in that
position you know i was young i was 18 i
got myself a credit card made a bunch of
purchases that i couldn't pay blah blah
blah long story short i wish i had
something to help me build my credit
back up now i'm good and you can be good
too the extra card is not a credit card
it's a debit card you sign up to extra
you get yourself that debit card you
link it with your account and you make
purchases and when you make purchases
they spot you and they pay themselves
the next business day and at the end of
the month payments are tallied up and
reported to the credit bureau and on top
of that you can get redeemable points
you're spending you're getting points
and you're helping yourself build your
credit back up wonderful isn't it sign
up today for extra to build your credit
back up link is below or up or side i
don't know where he's gonna put it but
go on the link get your extra now
listen maybe it's just me maybe it's
just me
if you're having relationship drama and
you get up on social media platforms to
air that [ __ ] out to me that just
screams emotional instability
okay and you look undateable
sorry i don't know if this is a new age
thing i don't care if it is
there's something really weird about a
girl who
vents out her racial problems in such a
emotional high perfect i'm looking at
you like
why
to me it's just the idea that you're
gonna air out your your your
relationship during laundry in such a
hyper emotional way
looking that hysterical yeah you get
what i'm saying it's like you're filming
yourself outside of your ex house you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're just screaming i'm
looking at you like it might be good
entertainment
but i would never think of dating you
but so then you also doubly lack that
self awareness not recognize what you're
projecting to the world when you do that
but the thing is that it's like you know
what it is just
it's like the person who always gets on
their social media platforms and talks
[ __ ] about their significant other or
their exes all the time and every x was
the problem and they were the worst you
start looking at that person like first
off you're airing this out to the world
making them look terrible which you
chose them and two
you don't maintain privacy so if i get
with you and doesn't go well you're
going to air me yeah yeah right so
that's the kind of stuff that i think
about when i see this
yeah
yeah it's something there's something
really definitely something weird about
it yeah something like uh
uneasy about it and screaming it's
really like you're not talking to us you
want to talk to them so
there's always a thing about closer
there's some people that actually want
closure and there's a lot of people that
i feel like they do videos like that
that just that's the way they have
closure they're not talking to she's not
talking to us
when she said why
it's not us
she put it out there for us to see
but she's really talking to that dude
to have closure maybe nah i ain't no
psychologist
maybe i ain't no psychiatrist maybe it's
attention but that
may be attention possible because by
being extreme people get attention
um
yeah let me get that when you're feeling
down in the dark i feel you and
everything and stuff how many times
after a breakup a girl post a picture of
herself really real sexy be like oh the
caption oh you thought you was the one
but you just gonna be the one who misses
out i made that up okay but that's the
kind of captions i would read i'm like
okay we get a girl your butt hurt over
it you want to let him know that you're
doing it yeah you know what i'm saying
it's another version of just posting a
bunch of of memes about things or
inspirational quotes that means nothing
just indonesian you always call me dear
but she was not the hunter like some
[ __ ] like that just to catch
attention yeah yeah
yeah and it makes no sense guys my
advice to you if you're dealing with a
bad breakup or it didn't go the way that
you wanted put your phone
away put your phone away
it's okay to be hurt it's okay to be
disappointed her
feeling all those emotions right
irrespective whether or not it was silly
of her to get attached irrespective of
whether or not he let her on right her
hurt is real mm-hmm whether she chose to
this attachment and made a lot of bad
decisions
the feelings that she's feelings are
real so she needs to take whatever time
she needs to heal yep but don't heal on
social media jesus christ that is one of
the worst ways to do it you get what i'm
saying so um that'd be my main message
and guys like like i said people
wouldn't say whatever they want but
their actions generally dictate whether
or not they're interested in you
so
if he's not treating you like a
girlfriend i don't know why you would
think you were going to become one
people stop taking listening to what
people are saying stop watching how they
move you know one thing that people do
often times when they see these kind of
scenarios is they project their own
experiences on twit right if they've
been with a girl who is hyper
manipulative and just screaming all the
time they'll be like man this [ __ ] is
probably just being super clinky and
this and that and that and that right
and then women who felt used by a dude
will look at this situation but well you
just don't know what it's like to be led
on by a guy and then get [ __ ] and then
left right so everyone's going to
project their experience onto this one
because they identify with people but we
have to have to we don't know it's just
her story maybe the dude after a divorce
is feeling tremendously anxious and as
he gets closer to her he realizes he
still has feelings for his ex-wife
or as he's getting with her he realizes
i actually still want to be out here
[ __ ] other people or as he gets with
her he realized like all my insecurities
that i had in my x marriage are showing
up right now and i'm getting really
claustrophobic with this woman who
desperately want we don't know
we don't know so i'm not going to judge
her too heavily within that relationship
that i make i'm just looking at what she
said in that video and her posting which
i think is crazy
rough
after two months you post a video on
online three
it doesn't matter
that's crazy so anyways
um those are my thoughts about this
video um guys
put the phones down
please put the phone dump the phone down
all right
sir
step away from the phone imagine going
viral because you cried online
and everyone comes up to you like he's
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] it happened two
years ago yeah i just saw it yesterday
but anyways let us know what you guys
think in the comments below